A tribunal based at The Hague recently
issued an award in an international
arbitration involving the Philippines
and China. First, it found that China's
claims to historic rights in the South
China Sea have no basis either in
international law or in historical fact.
Secondly, it found that none of the
Spratly Islands are, legally speaking,
islands. Rather, they're rocks or parts of
the seabed exposed at low tide. That
means they don't generate large maritime
zones that states can claim as their own.
And finally, it found that China acted
illegally by denying Philippine
fishermen access to the Scarborough
Shoal, by destroying the marine
environment in and around the Spratly
Islands, and by building an artificial
island within the Philippines' exclusive
economic zone.
Why does this matter? Well, it severely
curtails the amount of maritime territory
that China can legally claim in the
South China Sea.
Secondly, it could and should serve as
the basis upon which future negotiations
over territorial dispersement could
proceed. And finally, how China reacts to
the ruling will clarify whether it's a
country that upholds the rule of law—or not.
How do you think China will respond to
The Hague tribunal's ruling? Let us know
in the comments and also let us know
what other topics you want AEI scholars
to cover in 60 seconds.